if you don't think that the government
is that bad and that the representatives
are uh you know great people if you
think that they're really great people
well then
why would they be spying on us but
that's the new thing that they're going
to be doing or i suppose what is old is
new again
um we've got a quote here from fox news
on monday
politico reported plans from the biden
administration to battle misinformation
in regards to the covet 19 vaccine
the white house has decided to hit back
harder on misinformation
and scare tactics after republican
lawmakers and conservative activists
pledged to fight the administration's
stated plans to go door to door
to increase vaccination rates political
road
the pushback will include directly
calling out social media platforms and
conservative news shows
that promote such tactics biden allied
groups including the democratic national
committee
are also planning to engage fact
checkers more aggressively
and work with sms carriers to dispel
misinformation about vaccines that is
sent over social media and text messages
okay so this is quite extraordinary did
you catch that part about
sms carriers that's the phone carriers
that's a t
that's t-mobile sprint do they exist
anymore that's verizon
okay what they are saying is that if you
send a text message to a friend or to a
family member or
to whoever and it includes whatever they
deem as misinformation that somehow
you're going to get a message on your
phone from the government and that's
going to be in cahoots
with the democratic national committee
like what is
going on here and who's going to decide
what misinformation is
and as we know over the last year and a
half they tell us one thing one day and
one
and then something else the next day so
they're going to have to be correcting
themselves
constantly but this does seem a little
bit like spying right like if
uh if you're you know private citizen
and you text your brother some
information whether the government likes
that information or not
what right does the government have to
read that private communication between
the two of you
and then send you messages like this is
the worst sort of authoritarian stuff
that governments
can do and they're doing it right here
and i by the way i once again want to
want to clap and congratulate for my
good
liberal friends my you know the 10
non-woke liberals who still remain like
bill maher
and the usual suspects who always you
know complain about woke-ism complain
about all the problems of the left but
then
vote these people in you always vote
these people in
and here they are ushering in all of the
worst
anti-liberal things possible so this is
deeply dangerous look we know that the
government spies on us right like
there's that famous moment from a couple
years ago when under oath
uh cia director james clapper that he
was asked if
uh the i believe it was the nsa was
spying
on americans and he goes like this
scratching the top said he goes
not wittingly and of course you may
remember that episode of seinfeld where
they talk about when you're lying
how you touch your face right so if it's
a little lie you touch down here and if
it's a bigger lie you touch up here and
if it's a big lie
up here and he was like scratching the
top of his head like a monkey
so it was an absolute lie so he lied
under oath
and then you know what happened to him
not only nothing he got a job as a cnn
analyst because that's what happens
in this ridiculous swamp of nonsense um
so this is this is dangerous stuff like
they're going to be reading your text
messages
and by the way you're allowed to have
opinions of things
on things you're allowed to have
opinions on whatever political thing
or medical thing or anything else as a
private citizen
well i think you're allowed to or at
least the way it was set up you're
supposed to be allowed to i guess
i guess not much longer in uh in biden's
america
um but you're allowed to share
misinformation
i mean that's just the truth that's
that's what the first amendment's all
about you're allowed to have an opinion
you're allowed to share thoughts you're
allowed to share correct thoughts and
incorrect thoughts and everything else
and
the idea that the government is now
going to be jumping in reading your text
messages sending you messages
what else are they going to do like
they're going to so it also said that
they were going to work with social
media companies so now are these social
media companies
tools of the government so if the social
media companies now
ban anybody or block anybody or whatever
blow up people's accounts
well is that now a direct assault on the
first amendment which says that the
government can't infringe on speech
right
like that's been the whole the whole
argument about
social media has been that these are
private companies whether that's true or
not
that these are private companies they
can do whatever they want well okay now
that we know that the government is
going to try to work with them to stop
the spread of misinformation
that kind of sounds like the government
would be infringing on your first
amendment so
lawyers lawyer up because this ain't
getting any better